we have the greatest trade in history
allegedly there is a wallet that
supposedly bought eight thousand dollars
of Shibu Inu one of these dog coins I
don't know anything about Shibu he knew
I don't want to spend the time to learn
anything about Shibu Inu but somebody
bought eight thousand dollars just over
a year ago they turned it into 5.7
billion dollars so that person if
they're watching this is probably saying
maybe you should have learned about
Shibu Inu from 8 000 to 57 billion in
roughly 400 days now there's a lot of
asterisks caveats and clarifications
that come with this but this may be the
single greatest trade of any individual
in the world
we went from eight thousand dollars to
5.7 billion now there is absolutely zero
reason
why somebody should be owning Shibu Inu
other than
it may go up because other people are
gonna buy it that's literally it
there's no development activity there's
no value underlying it Etc
you may hear all these other people on
the internet who tell you how great it
is buy it and you'll get rich and do all
this stuff when you come and watch this
show we're going to tell you the truth
every time
this
is dog poo poo
I would not buy this I don't know what
any I don't think my brothers bought any
of it or owned any of it and the reason
is because yes somebody bought eight
thousand dollars of it and turned into
5.7 billion but if you tried to go sell
that 5.7 billion of Shibu Inu
what would happen is that the price
would crash so drastically that I would
question whether you could get a billion
out let alone anything less and so
ultimately what we are watching is
there's pure speculation there is an
argument to be made from all these
people who say hey every single dog coin
that comes out from now whatever
platform it's on just go buy a thousand
dollars and see what happens
sure
but you also can go to the casino
and put it all on red or black or sit
down at the blackjack table and just hit
until you win or you lose
and so I think that what we have to
remember is that these stories are
hilarious
yes I see all the memes they tweeted me
every day
but there is no ultimate value if you
see Highly Successful People whether it
is an Elon Musk or a Mark Cuban or
anybody else and you ask them why did
they talk about it or why did they buy
some of it they bought essentially none
of it 1500 bucks or something and
usually what they say is it's fun it's
entertaining or it's a way for them to
teach their kids something
nobody
nobody
that is a sophisticated investor is
going and putting hundreds of millions
of dollars in Dubai Shibu Inu it's not
happening
most of the market cap value is on pure
retail speculation and as you can see
here if you were to look at the realized
price the actual value of what went into
it it's very very low it's peanuts
compared to something like Bitcoin or
the Global Financial system
the value is in the rapid price
appreciation
and that's what drives a really high
market cap
Shiba Inu is now literally worth more
than Deutsche Bank Robin Hood and
Dogecoin
it doesn't change the fact that it's
literally dog poo poo
stop buying this [ __ ]
because guess what happens all the
people earlier this year that were
buying Dogecoin and they thought it was
hysterical they've all lost money
and so there's two types of people that
you're gonna listen to there's the
people who tell you
what is the good long-term investment
strategy or process or framework
and they try to explain it's not about
getting rich quick
it's about making sure that you're gonna
get rich
and build a life of wealth and Financial
Security
if you are predicated your entire
investment strategy is based on the fact
that you've got to buy something today
and it's got to go absolutely parabolic
in order for you to build a life of
Financial Security you're probably wrong
it's probably not a good strategy if you
want to do that [ __ ] go to the casino
right or go and take 500 bucks and go
buy this nonsense and then hope that it
turns into something and that you can
flip it before
it ends up going to zero
But ultimately this is not an investment
strategy
and there's a lot of people I'm not
going to say their names but there's a
lot of people online
who keep talking about this stuff like
it's the next Amazon or Google and
they're wrong they're just wrong
and you can keep this receipt and we'll
come back to it and in a year from now
we'll look at the price and it'll be
down a ton and I'll say I told you so
and I don't care if people think that
I'm right I'm wrong I don't care if this
makes people happy or sad I literally
don't care I'm not touching this with a
20-foot pole and I don't think any
serious investor is buying a material
portion of their portfolio into this and
thinking that it's going to go up and
that that's going to be a good
investment strategy
so the one thing I explained to everyone
is if you want to buy things for
entertainment purposes knock yourself
out
I buy all kinds of dumb [ __ ] for
entertainment purposes
but it's literally minuscule it's
immaterial to any sort of Investment
Portfolio and I don't think of it as my
Investment Portfolio apply for
entertainment purposes no problem
but there's not a person I know who
thinks that this is real and so I get
it's the greatest trade of any
individual kind of
but it's basically like me saying hey I
just created a company and now all of a
sudden I sold one share to John
and my company has a trillion shares and
John bought the share for one dollars
and I have a trillion dollars
kind of
but nobody else is actually going to buy
it for a trillion dollars so ultimately
a price
and value of something
they end up meeting over the long term
the price and value end up meeting and
they find some equilibrium
the price can get ahead of the value and
the price can get below the value but
over the long term they meet
and the value is determined by what
someone
is actually over a long period of time
willing to buy it from you for the
prices in the short term what somebody's
willing to pay
but the true value is determined year
after year after year after year what is
someone willing to pay
so there's a lot of young people
watching this stuff
I get it there's lots of people who are
putting a little bit of money and it's
going up a lot
it's fun cool I got it
but please please please do not go put
50 of your portfolio into this stuff
because in a year I've been telling I
told you so